- This is my father Sasha.
A lot of you don't know my dad.
I love my dad very, very much.
Gotten some interesting comments
from the Larry King
episode that I did.
You know, they're like,
"Oh, you really give
your dad some good daps,"
and, you know, it's funny
my kids are getting older and
I'm becoming a more experienced
dad and I think that you know,
obviously, we got to know each
other in the late 90s and early
2000's because you
just worked so hard.
And I thank you for that, Dad.
I thank you so much for
sacrificing and I know you did
it in a selfish way 'cause
I do it too in a selfish way.
I know that it's your natural
state to be an entrepreneur
and build for yourself.
But it doesn't take away from
the fact of what you did and
what you established and how you
started the process of
our family being here.
Not only did you but
you brought the whole family
along with you including your
mom and your grandparents and
you came to this country
and you worked so damn hard.
You know it's funny, I think
through all our frictions in
building the business, it's
super easy and has always been
super easy for me to focus on
how we're different and what
I don't agree on but I've been
noticing a trend especially
maybe because I don't see you
every day like I used to and
I'm not around as much on a
everyday basis with
you but it's been
interesting to me over the last
24 months, 36 months to start
being more in tune than ever
with not our differences
but our similarities.
Back in the day, in the late 90s
or early 2000s, I really thought
that I was 90% mom and 10% you.
And that's really just because
I didn't know you as well, Dad.
It's funny to me to recognize
how much more similar
I am to you than I realized.
And, you know, I just want you
to know how much you mean to me
and even though
I think for a long time
in my 20s and 30s that
my own ego and my own pride
was so scared
for the narrative to
be that you're the reason
I was successful.
That you're, even to this day,
Dad, I know you
don't read the
comments on the internet.
You'd find it interesting
how many people in a
YouTube comment will say,
"Well, don't listen to this guy.
"His dad had a liquor store
and that's why he's successful."
I was so scared of that, Dad.
I was so scared of that
in my teens and my 20s.
It was the biggest fear I had.
And now, as those
negative comments
or people that push back
are the far minority,
I find myself being
passionate to make
sure that your legacy isn't
lost and what you did isn't left
behind and it doesn't become
the narrative of just what
I've accomplished without the
context of what you accomplished
and how much you
helped me to get there.
And so, I want you to know that
and I want you know it now,
not when you're 90 or 100 or 130
when you're on your deathbed but
I want you to know it now of
how much you mean to me and how
thankful I am and how much
I learned from the way that you
and mom and navigated and
how I do think my hard work and
my hustle is my separation
from the marketplace.
And I know that's a learned
behavior by watching
how you did it.
And I thank you from the
bottom of my heart and so,
I thought it was a
good time to say hey.
I love you.
(somber music)
Thanks for being
on the show, Dad.
- You're welcome.
(Gary laughing)
A little bit of me.
- We're changing the wine world.
- Who's more charismatic?
(Gary laughs)
My son or me?
(DRock laughs)
- Jesus.
They're gonna love
you for this episode.
You're gonna get more
votes that you deserve.
(somber music)